So prisons in America specifically are some
of the biggest, most dysfunctional businesses
we have in our society, and they are a business
because of the cheap and free labor.
When you read the 13th Amendment—that basically
was the amendment that broke through slavery
and freed the men and women who were enslaved
at the time—there is a clause in there that
allows for the re-enslavement of people in
the event that they’re convicted of a crime.
And so in prisons throughout our country,
you have people who are working for basically
free, and if they’re not working for free
they’re working for wages that, if we saw
that happening in another country, we would
be very critical of.
When I was in prison I worked for $0.17 an
hour; that was my starting rate working in
the kitchen.
But there are also big corporations who invest
in prison labor because they can get this
labor for $1.50 an hour.
The sad part about it is that, in turn, they
don’t even hire these men and women when
they’re actually released from prison.
Everything in prison has inflated costs.
It costs us—inside prison, when I was inside—anywhere
between $3 and $15 for a 15-minute phone call.
We don’t have to pay that out here in free
society.
There is a way that we can send emails to
men and women inside prison, and it cost five
cents every time we send that, whereas out
here in society we can send emails without
any charge.
And so there are so many ways that the prison
is exploited: the cheap labor, the cost of
services and goods, and it’s a model that,
sadly and unfortunately, has affected a large
segment of our society.
I think most people aren’t aware of why
the business models of prison exist, because
most of our society has been left clueless
in regards to how our judicial system works.
And it’s largely been through the effect
of campaigns that politicians have run for
years, this whole idea that one of the greatest
fears you should have is crime in America.
When you’re operating out of a space of
fear you’re not thinking clearly, so you’re
not willing to examine things that are right
in front of us.
And so the way that the prison system has
developed and evolved over the years, is it
originally started as government-run, state-run
institutions, and then people started seeing
investment opportunities when the states and
couldn’t keep up with the budgetary cost
of incarcerating so many people.
We currently have over two million men and
women incarcerated throughout the country,
and we represent five percent of the world
population, yet we incarcerate 25 percent
of the world’s incarcerated people.
And so, at some point, states could no longer
keep up with those budgets, private investors
moved in and seized an opportunity, and then
they started structuring laws in a way that
ensured that people continue to be incarcerated
for the most frivolous things.
Like, 40 years ago we didn’t have as many
laws on the books that we have now, and when
you look at how the war on drugs itself impacted
incarceration rates, if you follow that pathway
you’ll see how people seized on that opportunity
and began to invest in private businesses.